das ist eine frage notar und bei fiesen
fragen und sehr harmlosen fragen
kannst du wählen die roten sind fies
die grünen sind harmlos oh ich probiere
zuerst ein grünes okay mit dem start yeah
ist sehr hip nur dreh es ist es auf
englisch ja es ist auf englisch  Ich meine, ich werde
es lesen können, aber oh ja, wie
hast du es geschafft, so wundervolle Töchter zu erziehen,
die große Frage, ich habe es geschafft
, so wundervolle Töchter zu erziehen,
weil ich ihnen immer die Wahrheit
gesagt habe, ich sagte, du wirst tun, was du tust.
Ich kann dich nicht aufhalten, aber ich
werde dir sagen, was die Konsequenzen
sind, wenn du in diese Richtung gehst oder du das
tust oder du dies tust. Ich werde dir sagen
, was die Konsequenzen sind, und ich
war immer ehrlich zu ihnen und wenn
ich Fehler gemacht habe, habe ich ihnen gesagt, dass es mir
leid tut, dass ich unverantwortlich gehandelt habe, und
ich habe die Verantwortung, dein
Vater zu sein, weil ich immer dein Vater bin
und Ehrlichkeit das Beste ist, was du tun
kannst  deine Kinder, weil sie
dir dann die Wahrheit sagen a  Und der einzige Weg, wie du
im Leben existieren kannst, ist, wenn
dich jemand genug liebt, um dir die Wahrheit zu sagen, wenn nicht, ist
es hart und das passiert
vielen Menschen, und wir schließen
Michael Jackson ein, jemand musste
ihm die Wahrheit sagen, es ist wichtig, dass du
sag deinen kindern die wahrheit guter punkt
kein sehr guter punkt also bitte wähle einen
fiesen ich bin nicht wirklich nichts aber ein
bisschen es macht sehr spaß das ist mein gib uns gib
mir lampenfieber haha ist es wahr du ha
t einen kleinen hammer kanns
du  Nehmen Sie sich immer noch ernst, nachdem Sie in
einem Film wie SpongeBob gespielt haben. Absolut niemand
kann mich in Verlegenheit bringen. Ich kann mich nicht einmal in Verlegenheit bringen.
Ich habe es getan. Es ist SpongeBob
mein haus
es ist ein 700
50 Panels und es ist 12 Fuß lang und ich
liebe Spongebob Spongebob rockt Patrick ist
ein bisschen schwul, aber Spongebob rockt wirklich wirklich
ich liebe Spongebob es ist eigentlich meine
Lieblingsserie okay wenn das nicht böse ist
okay okay t  Wo mehr und dann eine Person,
bitte Ich dachte, es wird ein wirklich
schöner Spaß, das ist großartig, jetzt ist es
irgendwie beängstigend, aber Lampenfieber. Ja,
ich leihe mir eins aus.  Ich bin immer
erfolgreich, sobald ich in Texten singe
, die die Leute verstehen, sie sagen,
was mit dir nicht stimmt, warum singst du diese
Texte? Ich bin in Großbritannien erfolgreich, wenn
ich Peter Pan mache. Ich bin in Amerika erfolgreich,
wenn ich amerikanische Lieder gut singe  Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich Limbo-Tanz in Amerika singen könnte,
äh, das ist eine sehr lustige Frage,
wer diese Frage geschrieben hat, du weißt, du
verstehst meine Texte nicht, verrückt nach dir,
verrückt nach dir, weißt du, manchmal
verstehe ich nicht einmal die Texte und
Osten, du weißt, ich meine eigentlich den Text
zu Whiter Shade of Pale. Hast du jemals
dieses Lied gehört
?
high Ich habe gerade
geschrieben, du kennst Fand  Ango, was zum Teufel ist
Fandango? Niemand war zusammen
Wem die Texte scheißegal sind? Niemand
interessiert sich für die Texte
?
balance okay yeah also vielen
dank danke sehr viel
leidenschaftlich
du